>> Greg: WHAT DOES THE MEDIA
DO WHEN FACED WITH THE
POTENTIALLY POSITIVE DRAMATIC
ACHIEVEMENT INVOLVING
DONALD TRUMP?
YOU WILL FIND A SMALLER MORE
EMBARRASSING STORY AND PLAY IT
UP BIG.
CALL IT THE SPLIT SCREEN EFFECT.
>> IT'S BEEN SPLIT SCREEN KIND
OF MOMENT.
>> WAS SO INTERESTING TODAY IS
THE JUXTAPOSITION.
LITERALLY AND FIGURATIVELY
DELETE THE SPLIT SCREEN.
>> YOU HAVE TO SAY THIS IS A
CLASSIC TRUMP-ERA SPLIT SCREEN
STORY.
FOR WHAT LEMMINGS.
OVERSHADOWING WHAT'S IMPORTANT
TO YOU WITH SOMETHING IMPORTANT
TO THE MEDIA.
THAT MEANS THE SLOW AWKWARD
DIPLOMATIC PROCESS IN HANOI
THAT'S MEANT TO ENHANCE THE
SURVIVAL OF OUR COUNTRY MUST NOW
COMPETE WITH A GOSSIP SPECTACLE
FILLED WITH OLD NEWS.
GUESS WHO WINS, THE SPECTACLE.
THAT'S WHAT THE HEARING WAS FOR.
THE MEDIA KNOWS EVERY TIME TRUMP
GOES OVERSEAS HE WINS.
SO MAYBE THEY CAN DISTRACT YOU
WITH THIS GRATUITOUS DRAMA AND
IF THERE'S GOOD NEWS FROM HANOI,
IT'S JUST TOO OBSCURE THE
HEARINGS.
>> HE MAY TRY TO DISTRACT.
HE MAY MAKE A BAD DECISION WITH
KIM JONG UN.
>> INDUCES HIM TO OVERREACH, TO
BASICALLY HOPE THAT HE CAN PULL
SOMETHING OFF IN HANOI THAT WILL
OBSCURE THE OTHER STORY.
>> DOES THE PRESIDENT FEEL THE
NEED TO COME UP WITH SOMETHING
SPECTACULAR OUT OF THIS MEETING,
SOMETHING HE CAN TOUT AS A
HISTORIC AGREEMENT IN ORDER TO
OVERSHADOW WHAT WE ARE GOING TO
HEAR ON CAPITOL HILL TODAY?
>> Greg: ISN'T IT MORE LIKELY
THE REVERSE, THAT THE HEARINGS
ARE MEANT TO UNDERMINE THE
SUMMIT?
I KNOW EVEN WE TOOK ALL OF IT.
SUCKERS.
I'VE NEVER SEEN SO MANY PEOPLE
ROOTING FOR FAILURE.
TOM BRADY WASN'T EVEN PLAYING.
IT MIGHT BACKFIRE BY PLACING
THESE TWO STORIES SIDE-BY-SIDE
IT MAY CREATE THE REVERSE OF
WHAT THE PRESS WANTS.
WHAT'S MEANT TO UNDERMINE THAT
DAMN TRUMP DAMNS THEM.
MIGHT END A 70 YEAR WAR.
WE COULD PUT AN END TO THE FALSE
MISSILE ALERTS THAT STRUCK COURT
IN HAWAII BUT LET'S FOCUS ON
SLIMEBALL THEATER WHICH IS
PROTEIN POWDER FOR THE CONSENSUS
MEDIA.
IT'S LIKE COMPARING A CURE FOR
DISEASE WITH AN OLD JACKASS
RERUN.
NEVER HAS SOMETHING SO BIG BEEN
COMPARED TO SOMETHING SO SMALL.
MAYBE NOT.
BUT IT'S CLOSE.
JUAN, FOR DINNER, EACH MAJOR
PLAYER GETS TO INVITE TO GUESTS.
TRUMP INVITED POMPEO AND THAT
OTHER GUY.
WHO?
>> Dana: MULVANEY.
>> Greg: I THINK IT WAS A
SLIGHT TO DENNIS RODMAN.
>> Juan: HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
THERE.
WE ALL HAVE TO BITE OUR TONGUE
BECAUSE DENNIS RODMAN, IT TURNS
OUT HE WAS AN IMPORTANT PLAYER.
BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS.
WHEN I HEAR CHAIRMAN CUMMINGS
SAY THAT WHAT HAPPENED ON
CAPITOL HILL TODAY WAS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE HISTORY WILL RECORD
WHETHER OR NOT WE AT THIS MOMENT
STOOD TALL IN TERMS OF DEFENDING
DEMOCRACY, I DON'T THINK IT'S A
SMALL STORY.
AND I DON'T THINK JUST BECAUSE
THESE TWO GUYS HAD DINNER, THEY
HAVEN'T EVEN STARTED THE
HEARINGS YET, THAT WE SHOULD
IGNORE WHAT'S GOING ON HERE IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT IS OF SUCH
MAGNITUDE AND IMPACT TO THE
PRESIDENCY OF THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S THE WAY I FEEL ABOUT IT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS DONE OVERSEAS THAT
AMOUNTS TO SO MANY WINS.
THE FIRST TIME HE MET WITH THIS
GUY, WE DIDN'T GET MUCH OUT OF
IT.
>> Greg: WE HAVE GOTTEN A LOT
OF THINGS WHEN HE GOES OVERSEAS
AND HE'S PRETTY GOOD WITH
DIGNITARIES.
I THINK THIS IS A BIGGER STORY
THAN THIS STORY THAT WE ARE
COVERING.
>> Morgan: SOME PEOPLE HAVE
THE SUPER BOWL.
I HAVE NORTH KOREAN SUMMIT WEEK.
THE MAJOR THING AND WE TALKED
ABOUT IT YESTERDAY, THE PATIENTS
REQUIRED IN DIPLOMACY.
I DON'T THINK -- MAYBE WE WILL
HAVE A BIG WIN COMING OUT OF
THIS BUT I CAN SEE WHAT'S MORE
LIKELY IS ANOTHER SUMMIT MAY BE
AT THE END OF THE YEAR OR IN
2020.
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
NORTH KOREANS, THEY ARE STILL AT
WAR WITH US.
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH MANY OTHER
WARS SINCE THEN.
OR THINK THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
DOESN'T REALLY THINK ABOUT
NORTH KOREA.
THE AVERAGE NORTH KOREAN AND
LEADERSHIP THINKS THE AMERICANS
ARE OUT TO GET THEM AND ARE OUT
TO INVADE THEIR COUNTRY.
THAT'S THE MIND-SET OF THE
PERSON AT THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
TABLE.
I THINK THERE'S TWO THINGS TO
LOOK FOR AS THEY NEGOTIATE OVER
THE EVENING IS, IS THERE A PEACE
DEAL WHICH WOULD OFFICIALLY END
THE WAR AND WHAT HAPPENS WITH
SANCTIONS?
THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID HE'S
GOING TO KEEP ECONOMIC SANCTIONS
ON NORTH KOREA UNTIL THERE'S A
CONSENSUS ON WHAT
DENUCLEARIZATION MEANS.
IS THERE SOME SORT OF LENIENCY
ON THE SANCTIONS SO THAT THE
NORTH AND SOUTH CAN DO MORE
ECONOMIC PARTNERSHIPS, MORE
BUSINESS DEALS, THE
SOUTH KOREANS WANT THAT.
THOSE OF THE TWO THINGS I'M
LOOKING FOR THAT POTENTIALLY
COULD COME OUT OF THE SUMMIT
TOMORROW.
>> Greg: DANA, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS?
YOU DRESSED IN UNISON WITH
KIM JONG UN.
>> Dana: TRYING TO HELP GET
THE STORY OUT THERE.
I THINK THE TIMING OF ALL THIS
IS GOING TO WORK OUT IN
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FAVOR FROM A
MEDIA PERSPECTIVE.
THE MICHAEL COHEN HEARING WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN BEFORE MICHAEL
COHEN HAS TO GO TO JAIL, AND
THAT'S SOON.
IT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN ANYWAY.
TODAY WAS THE SET UP DAY AND
DINNER, THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
NEWS.
THIS HEARING NOW IS IN THE
BOOKS.
TOMORROW THE ENTIRE DAY IS
DOMINATED BY WHATEVER HAPPENS
STARTING THE COUPLE HOURS WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND KIM JONG UN.
HISTORY IS A LONG ARC.
CARING ABOUT A 24-HOUR NEWS
CYCLE.
LEADERSHIP IS DOING THE RIGHT
THING THAT YOU THINK IS THE BEST
FOR THE COUNTRY AND EXPLAINING
IT AS BEST YOU CAN AND LETTING
THE CHIPS FALL WHERE THEY MAY.
>> Greg: I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
THAT IF THIS WERE
PRESIDENT OBAMA, I WOULD BE
ROOTING FOR HIM.
ISN'T THAT WEIRD?
>> Jesse: YOU WOULD NOT.
>> Greg: YOU WOULD NOT.
I SENSE THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
ROOTING AGAINST WORLD PEACE.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE MORE
THREATENED BY TRUMP THAN THEY
ARE OF KIM.
I DO THINK, FOR THE MEDIA TO SAY
OH, MAN, THESE SPLIT SCREENS,
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT MAKE THE
SPLIT SCREENS.
LITERALLY.
IT'S THEIR JOB TO DO THAT.
AND THEY ORCHESTRATED THE SPLIT
SCREEN BY HAVING LANNY DAVIS
BRING COHEN ON THE SAME DAY AS
THE SUMMIT.
>> Dana: THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE
IT TOMORROW.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE NOT AS
SMART AS YOU ARE.
>> Jesse: THEY PONDER, IS
TRUMP GOING TO DO SOMETHING AT
THE SUMMIT TO OVERSHADOW THE
SPLIT SCREEN THAT WE CREATED TO
OVERSHADOW HIS SUMMIT?
IT IS SO STUPID.
TO THINK THAT LANNY IS WORKING
PRO BONO.
COME ON.
HE IS ON THE PAYROLL OF THE
CLINTON OR THE DEMOCRATS.
IT'S CLEAR THE DEMOCRATS ARE
USING COHEN AS A WEAPON TO
IMPEACH HIM AND THESE
PROSECUTORS IN THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT ARE GOING AFTER HIM IN
ORDER TO BURNISH THEIR
CREDENTIALS AND HELP PROPEL
THEIR POLITICAL CAREERS.
>> Greg: IF NOTHING HAPPENS,
SOMETHING STILL HAPPENS BECAUSE
YOU CAN ALWAYS RETURN TO
WHATEVER KIND OF COLD WAR YOU
WANT.
IF YOU DECIDE THAT YOU NEVER
WANT TO DO THIS, THEN YOU'RE
JUST HAPPY TO ALWAYS BE AT THE
MERCY OF SOMEBODY'S MISSILES.
I THINK THIS -- THE STEP THAT'S
BEEN MADE HAS BEEN GOOD.
>> Dana: EVEN PEOPLE WHO ARE
SKEPTICAL IN THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COMMUNITY, THEY HAVE
BEEN LIKE I WILL BE A SKEPTICAL
OPTIMIST.
>> Greg: THE BEST KIND OF